Is it okay if I proxy?
Sorry...
She'll speak to me through here
and then I'll just repeat
whatever she says.
Not she...
It.
It is a machine.
She wants to talk...
talk...
talk to you.
If I say no, it's just going to
send someone else, isn't it?
Probably.
You are the only person
on the planet
who can fulfill this quest.
You must locate
The Holy Grail.
The what now?
Mrs. Davis is all knowing
and all powerful.
She not only knows
you're coming for her
but she wants you to.
Then I better get going.
Wiley?
What is that on your face?
What? My stache?
A lot's changed
since I last saw you.
Meet the Resistance.
What are you resisting?
Same thing you are.
The Algorithm.
Mrs. Davis?
Don't give it a name!
No one calls Facebook “Doug”!
This is what it does.
Everyone you meet
is only trying to push you
into doing what it wants.
It's just a matter of time
before every person on Earth
does whatever it asks them to.
I'm the best weapon you've got.
Are you all out of your minds?
Hey, Mom!
Let’s party!
Hello?
Hi!
Um. I'm looking for the Grail.
The holy one.